we don't know who the president is we've
got all politics up in the air
and so on the one hand i think we need
to take a break from politics on the
other hand i think we need to
get prepared for what our political
culture is going to be like if
it turns out that the democrats have the
white house and so we've got to check
out some more woke commercials this
video is sponsored by fubo tv
at half the price fubotv is the best
alternative
to cable more about them later first i'm
now over eight on the woke commercials
in guessing even what they are selling
so let's see
now we i feel like we've all been
through the ringer the past few weeks
i think my senses are going to be a
little more honed in let's roll the
first commercial
hey hey you okay
i'm good
[Music]
it could be a car commercial
a little lesbian i think they're
lesbians right of course
[Music]
it could be like a home insurance
commercial
look at you hi baby
mom this is amy oh hi amy
hey dad hey i'm amy
hi nice to meet you are you hungry oh
that white guy doesn't like the lesbian
[Music]
things
darn white guys
[Music]
oh dad's happy to see the straight kids
he just doesn't like the lesbians
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
white neighbor lady doesn't like it
a white guy really hates the lesbians
happy birthday hey dad
hey night night
good night
it's kind of like over the top even if
there's a straight couple like you're
unmarried you're like lying around
kissing each other in your parents house
it's not it's not like really acceptable
[Music]
sharing a bed on mary you can't no
wonder the dad's upset
what is he doing
dad
it's like a movie i have no idea what
it's like there isn't a product
[Music]
did i do it right oh
the loving world starts with a loving
it's a home insurance
[Music]
show you're a proud parent
uh i for the first time in any of these
web commercials i thought i had it
because it was about the home which was
like one of my early guesses
oh man there was the one the one thing i
i missed the only suggestion was at one
point they eat a cookie right they eat
an oreo in the picture
oh man i knew earlier this month oreos
announced that they were going to go gay
because now every everything including
your cookies
has to have a political dimension to it
so i actually should have
i should have picked up in that detail
that was
i was so engrossed by the narrative of
the film you know that uh
and that like kissing scene you know
that i i just totally
i missed it that was on me i should
there were there were two hints there
were two hints there the cookies and
then
the fact that earlier in the month oreos
decided that they were gonna they were
gonna take a stand
okay well i guess i need to watch more
tv one great way to watch more tv is i
can tune into fubo tv if you're fed up
with paying high cable prices and
dealing with
shady cable companies there's finally an
alternative that gives you the cable tv
experience
at half the price that is called fubo tv
comes with over 100 of your favorite
channels including
complete coverage of all your favorite
sports with all local broadcasters
all major sports league networks nfl red
zone espn abc cbs
more than that and you can stream select
games in 4k
plus you can record your favorite games
and shows on fubotv's cloud dvr
and watch anywhere on any device fubotv
is easy to try
it takes just two minutes to sign up and
start streaming all your favorite cable
channels
no cable box required you can cut that
cord you can try for free and cancel
anytime no hassle
no gotchas really fabulous go out there
and check it out i know we're all
looking for alternatives to the old
cable package now
great way to do it sign up for a
risk-free seven-day trial of fubotv get
15 percent off your first month
by going to fubotv.com knowles k w l e s
that is fubo tv.com knowles canada wles
to start your free trial and get 15 off
your first month of fubotv
fubotv.com knowles i'm going to be
watching a lot more tv so that i can
get much better at guessing these
commercials we have one more don't we
so 0 for 9 let's see let's see if i can
even get one
out of ten that last one was a very
engrossing narrative
this one i've been told is more direct
let's play the tape
hey when we're older let's get married
you can't get married why not black
people can't marry white people
hey now from steven universe
kids don't be racist
cut okay people we just need to get
coverage we'll start again in five
there are two dudes though easiest job
i've ever done stuff like this doesn't
actually happen in real life
whoa there are you kidding it totally
does
just because this has never happened to
you doesn't mean it doesn't happen
oh wow i'm sorry seriously i didn't know
yeah everyone messes up sometimes but
you gotta realize it hurts to deal with
racism
and when people act like it's not real
it makes it feel even worse
you have to acknowledge racism to work
against it
you're right i can do that you kids
better work on this before the wedding
whoa that's just we only just met today
just like a cartoon okay
okay this one i do think i sort of want
to take credit credit for getting i
didn't
say it so there's no way for you to
believe me but i did think it was going
to be like a nickelodeon
or one of those type of channels you
know but i didn't know if it was going
to sell a product like is this a show
this could be a show when you look at
the kind of programming that kids see
today it
it's basically indistinguishable from
these liberal psas
what's so amazing about this too by the
way is
they focus they focus on the racism
to sneak in making little kids gay and
talk
and like that the redefinition of
marriage is just like not even something
worth considering
talking about that it is it's just a
it's a guaranteed
uh definition even though for all of
human history sexual difference
was fundamental to the definition of
marriage for all of human history until
like five minutes ago
but now we just have to assume that it's
not not uh
involved in the definition of marriage
at all so you focus on this racism thing
which nobody says right nobody comes out
and says you can't
we can't have any interracial marriage
that's evil
find me the person find me the one guy
in america who says that i i don't know
where you'll find him
but i think a lot of people object to
the
complete redefinition of marriage from
the supreme court bench basically from
anthony kennedy's pen
and there's no discussion about that if
you disagree with that you're a bigot
if you accept that there are biological
differences between men and women you're
a bigot you can't say that at all
and now they're doing it to the kids so
even though i didn't say it i didn't
vocalize i was too engrossed in this
weird ad
i want to take credit for getting that
one right and also i never
ever ever want to subscribe to cartoon
network maybe that will
convince me that we've got to cut the
cable box and go to
fubo tv please don't forget to post
other quote commercials that you want me
to review in the comments section
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you